when it comes to the
fast is it simply the doing away of food
drink and sexual relations or other
implications the things which are f for
a person who fasts as you mentioned
earlier one of them is to abstain from
things that break the fast that is food
drink and having sexual
relationship but besides this one
another important factor is is the
intention is the
Nia any deed without the
Nia for the it is useless the should be
there the near the intention is very
important because we intend to fast to
pleasa Allah subhana tala it's act of
worship if this intention is not there
then there are various different types
of fast for example a person may fast
for political reason
a person may fast as a passive
resistance a person may fast as hunger
strike I'm starving hunger strike to get
whatever he wants you know are people
fasting non-muslims fasting a person may
fast for health
reason maybe for dieting he may fast
maybe to lose weight he may fast it may
be a medical treatment but all these
fast they do not have an intention the
near to pleas Allah subhana tala so that
the reason Reon in the Islamic Sharia
when we abstain from things that break
the fast it should be accompanied by the
ni without the
Nia the fast is useless it's very
important Nia is compulsory for every
act of worship including fasting and I
belov it Prophet M said it's mentioned
in s Muslim volume number 2 in the book
of zakat chapter number 370 Hadith
number 2198 our beloved Prophet said
that when you have
intention to approach your wife to have
relationship with your wife the moment
you have intention even that becomes
charity the sahabas asked having
relationship with your wife is also
charity how come beloved Prophet The
Prophet said that if you have sexual
relationship with people who are not
your wives if it's unlawful isn't it a
sin they said Yol Allah yes it is a sin
so that is if you have sexual
relationship with the person you're
supposed to have that is your wife with
the Nia that's an act of Charity that
means Nia is very important the moment
you have neara then you get for that and
Allah says in the Quran in Surah Bay
chapter number 98 verse number five it's
mentioned and he commanded that you
worship him alone and in sincere
devotion true in faith here the word
used is which means to worship but
actually Abu it means to Humble but the
wordu in Arabic is normally used for
worship it actually means to Humble the
other Arabic word used is M which means
to serve with piety and with
dedication so here we should serve only
for Allah and a worship should be to him
alone that should be that is the
intention and Allah says in the Quran in
Surah Bak chapter number two verse
number 29 that we have created for you
everything on this earth when Allah has
created everything in this Earth for us
not 1110th not 1/5th not 1/4th not half
but everything for the human beings in
this Earth so but natural our servitude
should only be to him and no one else if
while worshiping him we worship somebody
else then it is useless we have to only
worship him and no one else we can't say
that I praying two raat for Allah and
two raat for somebody else we can't say
I'm sacrificing one goat for Allah and
the second goat for a king or a ruler
all our worship should be to him alone
and no one else and that reminds me of
Hadith the first Hadith
inkari where be pleased with him he says
that the Beloved Prophet wasam
said your Deeds are based on your
intention your action are judged by
intention and anyone who has migrated
with the intention for he has migrated
for but if someone has migrated for the
wealth in this world or for marriage he
has migrated for the wealth and marriage
the intention is important why did you
do it and why did you migrate why you do
Jihad so
intention is very important for any act
of worship including s that is fasting